[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابره
العرب
دار موزور دوله
زندونيون موجود بين ايران
واشنطن تكذب طهران لا اتفاق حول الافراج
عن عشره مليارات دولار مقابل رهن امريكيين
متهور سيحاسبه تاريخ ولن ادعمه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي يستنفر وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه ويثير دار الاسواق
العالميه والامريكيه والبريطانيه
[موسيقى]
لقائمه مقاطعي تيك توك والعربيه تفتح ملف
امن المعلومات على منصات التواصل
[موسيقى]
اتفاق مبدئي بين واشنطن وطهران للافراج عن
رهاء مزدوج الجنسيه اعلن عنه وزير
الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير عبد الله
ونفاه البيت الابيض ورغم ان عبد الهيان
قال ان طهران تسعى لتنفيذه في اسرع وقت
الا ان البيت الابيض اشار الى ان
التصريحات كاذبه مصادر العربيه افادت ان
الصفقه بين واشنطن وطهران تتضمن اطلاق
ايران ثلاث رهائن امريكيين مقابل افراج
واشنطن عن اموال لطهران مجمده في العراق
واليابان وكوريا
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو زميله
ناديه البلبيسي مراسله العربيه في واشنطن
بدايه النادي اهلا وسهلا العربيه وليس
للحديث عن هذه الصفقه لماذا الادعاء
الايراني بهذا التوقيت بالذات اولا نبدا
برد فعل البيت الابيض اللي هو متوقع على
كل الاحوال البيت الابيض ينفي بان هناك
افراج وشيك عن الثلاثه طبعا او السجناء
الامريكيين الايرانيين المحتجزين في ايران
هذا شيء متوقع اولا لانه البيت الابيض
سينتظر حتى اللحظه الاخيره حتى يتم رسميا
اطلاق سراحهم يصعدون الى الطائره سيكون
هناك شخص مستوى
حسب معلوماتي المصادر التي اتحدث معها
دائما تقول بانه هناك تفاوض امريكي ايراني
منذ فتره طويله المشكله عالقه حول الاموال
يعني هناك ثلاثه اسماء سيتم اطلاق صراحه
مساعدات انسانيه بمعنى بان ايران لن
تستخدمها لربما اغلاق الاموال على وكلائها
في المنطقه او على اي نشاطات اخرى تماما
غير يعني
بالتجربه مع النظام الايراني لم تستطع اي
من الادارات الامريكيه ضبط سلوك هذا
النظام هل ممكن فعلا مراقبتها بشكل يعني
تام وكامل هذه هي النقطه الاهم في هذا
الاتفاق لذا اعتقد بان البيت الابيض متردد
جدا بان يقول بان توصلنا الى الاتفاق بعد
تامين هذا المبلغ لاكثر من سبب اولا اداره
هذا الرئيس اداره الرئيس بايدن ستتعرض
لضغوط قويه جدا من الجمهوريين في الكونجرس
خصوصا اذا كانت هناك مثلا نقول الاموال في
العراق اذا كان هناك اتفاق على الافراج
عنها وتم استخدامها لاغراض غير انسانيه
بين قوسين الرئيس سيحاسب وقد تكلفه سياسيا
الانتخابات يعني صوري كم هو الموضوع حساس
بالنسبه لاداره رئيس بايدن وهذا ما حدث في
عهد اداره الرئيس السابق
اعتقد بان هناك
نيه للافراج عن هؤلاء وخصوصا الثلاثه طبعا
هذه الاسماء التي انا اطرحها تقريبا في
الاجازه الصحفي في البيت الابيض بشكل شبه
يومي عندما نسال كريم جانبير حسب معلومات
بانه
الافراز سيكون عن كما تعرفين سماك نمازي
سيكون عن مراد تحباز وعن عماد شغلي لكن
هناك ايضا اثنين لن يضمهم هذا الافراج
لاحقا اذا تمت الصفقه الصفقه فقط متعلقه
يعني هناك ضمانات امريكيه بانه هذه
الاموال بالفعل ستصرف على اغراض انسانيه
لكن البعض يشكك كثير بانه ايران ممكن تضغط
على مثلا بعض البنوك في العراق بان تفرج
هذه الاموال ولا تستخدم
تماما وايضا اريد بس انوه الى شهاب دليلي
لن يكون ضمن الرهان الذي سيفرج عنهم لانه
لم يحصل على الجنسيه الامريكيه كان على
قصيره جدا لاصبح مواطن امريكي لكن اعتقل
في ايران قبل ذلك وبالتالي ايران ربما
ستحتفظ به الى مرحله لاحقه لكن هناك رابطه
فعاله في واشنطن وهي تسمى حسج ايز تهتم
بكل المواطنين الامريكيين المحتجزين في
ايران وفي غير ايران تقول بانه على
الاداره الامريكيه بقياده رمالي ان تؤمن
سراح اطلاق سراحه كل الرهائن الامريكيين
شكرا لك ناديه البلبيسي على هذه المعطيات
وعلى وجودك معنا شكرا الك ليان
[موسيقى]
الجماعيه او الاثار النفسيه والعقليه
والتوتر اسلحه النظام الايرانيه الجديده
التي يشهرها بوجه النساء فهذه تفسيرات
للسلطات لما يحدث في مدارس البنات حاليا
منها هجمات بالسم الخفيف فمن منظارها 10%
فقط من الحالات حقيقيه والباقي يقع بخانه
الخوف الجماعي مصطلح الهستيريا الجامعيه
ليس وليد اللحظه وانما كان شائع الاستخدام
في افغانستان بين عامي 2012 و 2016 عند
تكرار حالات تصميم الطالبات الامم المتحده
وبعد تحقيقات مطوله حينها نفت قدرتها على
ايجاد ادله لاثبات التسمم بالغاز او السم
لتخلص الى انها امر نفسي مع العلم بان
ثاني اكسيد النيتروجين يتحلل بسرعه وفق
ايران انترناشونال وبحسب اخر تقدير
للتحالف العالمي لحمايه التعليم الهجمات
18 بلدا يعانون من النزاعات شهد حالات
مماثله بين عام 2014 وعام 2018 من بين هذه
الدول المشاهدين افغانستان والكاميرون
ومصر والعراق وليبيا وباكستان وسوريا
وتهدف هذه الهجمات تاريخيا لمحاربه تعليم
المراه ما يمهد الطريق امام تزويجها
بالاجبار
[موسيقى]
الهجمات الكيماويه على مدارس البنات في
ايران جرسوا انذار للبحث في حل عاجل
لحمايه حق الفتيات في التعليم وتحقيق
المساواه بين الجنسين مجموعه بارزه من
النساء الافغانيات والايرانيات سياره حمله
تدعو الى الاعتراف بالفصل العنصري بين
الجنسين كجريمه بموجب القانون الدولي
الحمله التي انطلقت في اليوم العالمي
للمراه اكدت ان القوانين الحاليه التي
تعطي التمييز ضد المراه وتغطيه لا تعكس
الطبيعه السياسيه المنهجيه المفروضه في
افغانستان وايران لخفض مكانه المراه في
المجتمع ومن الموقعين على الرساله
المفتوحه شيرين عباد الايرانيه الحائزه
على جائزه نوبل للسلام وفوزيه في اول
نائبه لرئيسه البرلمان الافغاني وفق صحيفه
الجارديان يذكر مشاهدينا انه في حين ان
هنالك جريمه فصل عنصري في القانون الدولي
الا انها تنطبق فقط على المجموعات العرقيه
وليس على الجنس
[موسيقى]
اتساع ورقعه الهجمات الكيماويه بمدارس
البنات في ايران دفع السلطات لسلوك
التجاعيد اولهما التشكيك بصحه الهجمات
والثاني اتهام الغرب بالوقوف ورائها اخر
هذه الاتهامات ساقها موقع اخباري ايراني
يديره الحرس الثوري للسفير البريطاني في
طهران بالتورط بشكل مباشر بموجه التسمم
حيث شبه موقع مشرق نيوز سياسه السفير
البريطاني بتعليمات نادي تشرشل دون تقديم
دليل على ادعاءاته علما بان نادي تشارتش
هو مجموعه من تلاميذ المدارس الدنماركيين
الذين ارتكبوا اعمال تخريب ضد الالمان
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه واضاف الموقع
ان مراجعته للانشطه حول المدارس اظهرت ان
جهاز المخابرات للعدو والشبكه المظلله
ينفذان هذا المشروع لاعاده اشعال اعمال
الشغب في الشوارع التي خمدت وفق تعبيره
[موسيقى]
قنبله
مؤقتات تهدد وموقوتات تهدد ايران ونصف
سكانها مع وصول القشره الارضيه فيها الى
حاله وصفت بالحرجه للغايه احدث التقييمات
والخرائط اشارت الى ان المساحه التقريبيه
لمناطق الهبوط الارضي في ايران تصل الى
اكثر من 18 مليون هكتار اي ما يعادل 11%
من اجمالي مساحه ايران بمعنى ان اكثر من
39 مليون شخص معرضون للخطر اي ما يعادل 39
او 49% من سكان البلاد القشره الارضيه
مشاهدينا التي تمر باسوء حالاتها قد تعرض
380 مدينه وتسعه الاف ومئتي قريه لخطر
هبوط الارض بسكانها وفق طبعا خبراء اما
اكثر المحافظات عرضه لهذا الخطر فهي
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران وخرسان واصفهان
فيما محافظه خرسان المرتبه الاولى من حيث
المساحه للمناطق المعرضه لخطر الهبوط علما
بان مناطق سهل مشهد شمالي شرقي ايران سجلت
بالفعل حالات هبوط ارضيه واسعه تراوحت بين
ثلاثه سنتيمترات و17 سم وفي حين ان الهبوط
الذي يتم التحكم فيه في دول مثل اليابان
والولايات المتحده والصين يصل الى سنتيمتر
واحد في السنه يؤكد خطوره الوضع في ايران
وصول الهبوط الارضي الى هذه المرحله من
التازم سببه طبعا الجفاف الدائم
والاستخدام المفرط للمياه الجوفيه
والسياسات الخاطئه واثاره دائمه كموت
طبقات المياه الجوفيه وتدمير الزراعه
وتحويل السهول لسحاره وخلق شقوق عميقه ما
يهدد احيانا استمرار الحياه في منطقه
جغرافيه محدده
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بولندا اكبر منفق على التسليح بين دول
الناتو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في تداعيات انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي الامريكي تدرس مؤسسه التامين
على الودائع الفيدراليه والاحتياطيه
الفيدراليه انشاء صندوق يسمح بدعم المزيد
من الودائع في البنوك التي قد تواجه مشاكل
بعد انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي وقد ناقش
المنظمون انشاء شركه ذات اغراض خاصه بحسب
مصادر وكاله بلومبر بهدف طمنت المذيعين
ياتي ذلك بعد القلق بشان صحه البنوك
الاصغر التي تركز على شركات راس المال
المغامر وشركات الناشئه هذا ومن المنتظر
ان يعقد الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الاجتماعا
طارئا يوم الاثنين لمناقشه ازمه هذا البنك
[موسيقى]
موجه من الخسائر تكبدتها اسهم البنوك
العالميه يوم الجمعه الماضي معا انهيار
بنك سيليكون فالي في الولايات المتحده
الذي يعتبر الاكبر منذ الازمه الماليه
العالميه ففي خطوه سريعه لحمايه اموال
المودعين قامت الجهه التنظيميه للقطاع
المصرفي في ولايه كاليفورنيا باغلاق
مجموعه بنك سيليكون فالي اذ حاول
المستثمرون والمودعون سحب 42 مليار دولار
من البنك يوم الخميس الماضي وفقا لافصاح
تنظيمي وفي ختام الاعمال في التاسع من
مارس كان لدى البنك رصيد نقدي سلبي قدره
958 مليون دولار البنك الذي تركز انشطته
على الشركات الناشئه تكبد خسائر قدرها
مليار و800 مليون دولار في بيع سندات
الخزانه الامريكيه والاوراق الماليه
المدعومه بالرهن العقاري وقام بوضع خطه
لجمع مليارين ومئتين وخمسين مليون دولار
من
وهي شركه ناشئه تقدم حسابات جاريه عاليه
العائد للشركات الناشئه ان الاسبوع الماضي
كان بلا شك الاسبوع الاكبر في تاريخ
الشركه من حيث نمو الودائع حيث شهد راس
المال عشره اضعاف حجم الودائع مقارنه
بالاسبوع الذي سبق بالاضافه الى زياده
مضاعفه في اجمالي قاعده الودائع هذا وتسود
حال من القلق مؤسسي شركات الناشئه بشان
تمكنها من الاستمرار في دفع رواتب
الموظفين بعد فشل از في بي وفيما يخص
العملات المشفره انخفضت ثاني اكبر عمله
مستقره او ستيب الكون من السعر المثبت
بدولار واحد يوم السبت متاثره بتعرض
المصدر سيرك الانترنت فاينشر لبنك سيليكون
فالي المنهار سعى حمدان العربيه
وبعد انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي اكدت وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه ان الاقتصاد الامريكي
والنظام البنكي سيظلان امنين اشارت الى ان
انهيار سيليكون فالي بانه صادم ومقلق
ولكنها لفتت ايضا الى ان مرور احد البنوك
بازمه لا يعني ان بقيه البنوك ستعاني
اضيفتان ان الاداره الامريكيه تسعى لعدم
انتقال مشاكل بنك سيليكون فالي الى بنوك
اخرى
[موسيقى]
للحديث مشاهدينا عن انهيار هذا البنك عن
تداعياته على الاسواق الماليه العالميه
فينضم الي بالسجود وليد الحلم مدير ابحاث
السوق في امانه كابيتال بالبدايه اهلا
وسهلا بك بالبدايه السؤال الاساسي ما هو
الاستثمار يعني الخاطئ الذي قام به هذا
البنك وسمح وادى الى نتيجه هذا الانهيار
يمكن الاقبال الكبير من المذيعين او زياده
الايداعات اللي حصلت بناء على الاقبال
الكبير على استثمار في قطاع التقنيه اللي
حصل في العمل الماضي ادى الا ان البنك
يوصل لحد معروف عند البنوك وهو حد الايه
الايداعات الزائده وده بيكون مستوى من
الايداعات لم لا يطابق او يكون غير مناسب
للاستثمارات فاضطروا ان هم ياخذوا مجموعه
من القرارات ان هم يستثمروا في اصول
العوائد بتاعتها اصبحت منخفضه جدا زي مثلا
السندات الرهن العقاري وما شابه نعم هي
سندات او اصول ماليه جيده ولكن لا تتطابق
مع معدلات الفائده المرت
[موسيقى]
بسرعه يعني قياسيه اليوم العين على
اجراءات الامريكي ما المتوقع ان يفعله لان
هذه الساعات هي حاسمه غدا ستفتح الاسواق
الماليه وبالتالي ممكن ان تنسحب ازمه هذا
البنك على البنوك الاخرى صحيح انا يعني
واضح عندنا ان في امرنا هيكونوا موجودين
الامر الاول ان الحمايه او الانشورنس اللي
موجود من المؤسسه الفيدراليه لتامين
الودائع اللي انت تكتفي فقط ب 25 او 250
الف دولار زي ما كان زي ما هو القانون
المتعارف عليه بل سيتم تعويض كل كل من
كانوا لديهم اموال موجوده اعتقد ده ممكن
يكلف الحكومه في حوالي 50 مليار دولار دي
اعتقد دي كميه العجز اللي موجوده عندنا
الامر الاخر وده يمكن اللي عائلتها جنتل
ان النهارده ان هو لن يتم انقاذ البنك في
اشاره الى ان اي بنك سيتعثر في المستقبل
الحكومه ستكون مسؤوله عن
المذيعين ولن تكون مسؤوله عن البنوك اللي
تاسست خلال الفتره القادمه وخصوصا احنا
بنتكلم على البنوك الصغيره او المتوسطه
لان اول ما الناس بتبتدي تشك هتبتدي تنقل
هذه الاموال للبنوك المتعرف عليها اللي هو
اي حد راح الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تعمل معها او شافها في الشارع مش البنوك
المتخصصه اللي زي دي الخوف الاول اذا على
المرحله الاولى هي على انسحاب هذه الازمه
الازمه على البنوك الاخرى وبالتالي اتخاذ
خطوات سريعه المرحله الثانيه هي موضوع
الفائده يعني هنا نعود لنتحدث عن جدوى
الرفع كيف سيتم التعاطي مع هذا الموضوع
خصوصا انها سبب اساسي بهذا الانهيار
بالضبط يمكن احنا لما نتكلم على ان
الطرفين المعنيين بهذا الموضوع البنك
المركزي وزاره الخزانه الاثنين يعني كانت
المحافظه السابقه للفدرالي الامريكي انا
اعتقد ان ده لغايه دلوقتي مش هياثر على
السياسه الخاصه لان احنا لو اتكلمنا
بالنسبه للمخاطر اللي بتحصل هي ليست
موجوده للقطاع البنك كله ولكن موجوده في
القطاعات المتخصصه لعانه
القطاعاتها عانت من تراجعات كبيره يعني
شفنا سيلفر جيت واحنا بنتكلم على 40 مليار
حجم الايداعات اللي كانت موجوده بنتكلم
دلوقتي على اس في بي الحجم المتوسط
الايداعات اللي موجوده حوالي اخر رقم كان
موجود نهايه 2022
كان اكتر من 200 مليار بالنسبه لسكيل
البنوك لا يعني دي مش مش سيستمات الكريسك
في وجهه نظري دي ازمه موجوده في البنوك
المتخصصه الصغيره والمتوسطه تقريبا اليوم
وفي الاساسي وايضا هو تمويل الاساسي
الموجود بالبنوك هي للشركات الناشئه
وتحديدا التكنولوجيه منها هناك يعني ازمات
متتاليه على موضوع على قطاع التكنولوجيا
هناك تخوف اليوم بريطاني من ان تؤدي هذه
الازمه الى يعني الحد من التمويل لشركات
الناشئه كيف ممكن ان يتم تخطي هذه الازمه
فوجد نظري الموضوع صعب لان المشكله ان
شركات التقنيه دايما بتتعمل بتتعمل
بالمودل الخاص بالنمو يعني الاختيارات
الكثير من الاموال وضخها زي ما يسمى
بحرقها لتحقيق اكبر نسب نمو موجوده في ظل
فوايد مرتفعه ده مش هيوفر المناخ الجيد
بالنسبه لكثير من الاستارز وحتى الشركات
الكبيره يمكن حتى الاستراتيجيه المشهوره
بالاستثمار في المراحل اللي احنا موجودين
فيها الشركات اللي هي كشريتش اللي هي معها
اموال ولا تحتاج ان هي تقترض خلال هذه
الفتره تكلفه الاقتراض بقت كبيره وما بقتش
متوفره لانها ما بقتش مفضله بالنسبه
للبنوك ما يسمى في الاقتصاد بانقلاب منحنى
العائد اصبح ان العوائد قصيره المدى اغلى
من العوائد طويله المدى فلما البنك يحاول
يعمل الكلاسيكيات الخاصه به بان هو يقترض
على مدى قصير عشان يقرض على المدى الطويل
هذا الفرق اصبح خساره بالنسبه له هي دي
النقطه الرئيسيه يمكن احد المخاوف الممكن
تكون موجوده بالنسبه للسوق ان الضغط ده
ينتقل بان الاموال كلها تنتقل من البنوك
الصغيره والمتوسطه تروح للبنوك الكبيره
نعم دي بنوك اداعتها تريليونيه وعليها جدا
كبيره ولكن ايضا ممكن توصل للحد الاكسسف
الخاصه بها وهنا الحكومه لازم هيكون ليها
دور في هذه المرحله اليوم هناك اض
طراب اطلاق الماليه ان كان الامريكيه وان
كان البريطانيه او العالميه كيف يمكن
طمانه الناس ويعني هناك حاله هلع يعني ما
الخطوات الملموسه التي ممكن ان تطمئن
الناس اليوم التعويض كل الدائنين
الكل مش الحد الاقصى لان على فكره الناس
اللي تنطبق عليهم القانون الخاصه بالتعويض
بالنسبه لمؤسسه الفيدراليه يعني حوالي 6%
97% لا ينطبق عليهم هذا الامر فالحل هو
تاكيد الثقه في القطاع المالي الخاص في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وده من اهم
الاولويات اللي موجوده عندهم بان يتم
تعويض كل من تضرروا في هذا الامر العملات
الرقميه اتت لتقول انا احل مكان العمله
التقليديه في البنوك اليوم كيف يمكن ان
تستفيد من هذه الازمه ام ان ازمتها
الاخيره لا يمكن ان تسمح لها بالاستفاده
منها يمكن احنا شفنا في
سيليزيوسنا في كل هذه الامثله انهم
العملات المشفره غير جاهزه خلال الفتره
القادمه او على الاقل خلال عشر سنين قادمه
ان هي تقدر تحل مشكله من هذه المشاكل لان
المشكله مع اي مؤسسه ماليه شفناها بالنسبه
للعملات المشفره كانت نتيجتها انهيار
خصوصا مع ضعف او انعدام الريجوريشنز اللي
موجوده او ما يسمى التشريعات اللي موجوده
على العملات المشفره فوجئت نظري انعدام
الضامن بالضبط
ولكن هناك لا مؤسسه قانونيه ضامنه شكرا لك
وليد الحلو مدير ابحاث السوق في امانه
كابيتال على وجودك معنا
اعتقد ان اول شيء يجب قوله هو ان محافظ
بنكي انجلترا المركزي قد اوضح تماما انه
لا توجد مخاطر منهجيه على نظامنا المالي
لذلك يجب طمانه الناس على هذا الاساس ولكن
هناك خطر جسيم على تقنيتنا وقطاعات علوم
الحياه والعديد منها يتعامل مع هذا البنك
الذي لم يسمع به معظم الناس
[موسيقى]
في الولايات المتحده يزيد الصراع
الانتخابيه حماسا كلما اقترب الموعد
والجديد جاء من تصريح المفاجئ لنائب رئيس
الامريكي السابق مايك بانس موجها اياه
لترامب قائلا التاريخ سيحاسبك على دورك في
هجوم هذه التصريحات ستؤدي بحسب مراقبين
الى تعميق الخلافات بين المرشحين السابقين
منذ ان رفض بانسا المشاركه في جهود ترامب
لالغاء نتائج انتخابات 2020 والبقاء في
السلطه باد في كلمه القاها في حفل العشاء
في واشنطن يقيمه صحفيون سنويا للقاء كبار
السياسيين قال ان رئيس ترامب كان مخطئا
مضيفا تصريحات تراب المتهوره عرضت عائلتي
وكل شخص في الكابيتال للخطر في ذلك اليوم
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تصريحات
خطيره لمايك بينس تضع مستقبل ترامب
السياسيه على المحاك المنافسه داخل الحزب
الجمهوري تشتد لنيل الثقه للترشح في
الانتخابات المقبله هذه المره مايك بينس
يدخل في خط المواجهه ويكثف من انتقاداته
لمثير الشغب والترامب هجوم مبنى الكابيتول
عام 2021 هو الباب الامثل ليدخل منه في
صراعه مع ترامب
دونالد ترامب بتعريض عائلته والجميع في
مبنى الكابيتال للخطر بل اكد ان ترامب كان
مخطئا للدعائه كان لديه سلطه الغاء نتائج
الانتخابات عام 2020 تعليقات وصفت بالحاده
حول دور الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب في
الهجوم على مبنى الكابيتال مع فتح وزاره
العدل البابا امام مقاضاه ترامب في
مسؤوليته عن هج وم الكابيتال لم يفوت بانس
الفرصه في الهجوم على الترامب بعدما كان
يرفض التعاون مع لجنه مجلس النواب المعنيه
بالتحقيق في الهجوم
[موسيقى]
برنامج انفاق دفاعيه ضخم تنتهجه بولندا
لتجديد عتادها المثقل بكثير من معدات
الحقبه السوفيتي ومواجهه اي تهديد روسي
على حدودها وزير الدفاع البولنديه اكد ان
الطبيعه غير المتوقعه لبوتين تبرز الحاجه
لتسريع تحديث المعدات بشكل اكبر وارسو
قررت هذا العام انفاق اربعه بالمئه من
ناتجها المحاليل الاجماليه على الدفاع
ومبلغ ضعف متطلبات
وسيجعل بولندا اكبر منفق على الدفاع في
الحلف من حيث نصيب الفرد ومالكه اكبر قوه
دبابات في اوروبا فبحسب ذيله الاجراف
عمليات شراء الاسلحه التي اقدمت عليها
بولندا مؤخرا قدمت قدرات بريطانيا
الدفاعيه واصولها من الدبابات الذي يشمل
227 دبابه ومن ضمن مشتريات بولندا 1000
دبابه قتال رئيسيه من كوريا كيتو الجنوبيه
و250 دبابه ابرمز الامريكيه كما سيتم
تعزيز مدفعيتها ب 600 مدفع هاوتر كي 9 و 8
عشره قاذف تايمرز وتسعه الاف صاروخ
[موسيقى]
ميدانيه في اوكرانيا تدخل معركه بخموت
المستمره منذ قرابه الثمانيه شهور مرحله
جديده مع اعلان الدفاع الروسيه سيطرتها
على 50% من المدينه حيث كانت ولا تزال
مخموت نقطه محوريه في القتال العنيف بين
الجيش الاوكراني والقوات المواليه لروسيا
وتحديدا
المعارك في بخموت تاخذ منحا جديدا باعلان
فاجنر سيطرتها على جنوب المدينه رغم شح
الذخيره الذي بات مشكلا يؤرق الطرفين
المقاومين الاوكران والقوات المواليه
لروسيا وفقا لتقرير صادر عن صحيفه قوه
راجنر ستسعى في المرحله المقبله الى
اعتماد استراتيجيه جديده تساعد في تحقيق
مكاسب اكبر وتجنب خسائر محتمله حيث كشف
يفجيني انه سيتم اصلاح المجموعه واعاده
هيكلتها وتصميمها بشكل يضمن تحولها الى
منظمه عسكريه موازيه من النقبه للجيولوجيه
خطوه ستضمن دورا مهما لقوات راجنار في
اوكرانيا التي ستكون مرهونه بموجه جديده
من التجنيد عبر روسيا التي ستتبع لانشاء
جيش دي مكون ايدولوجي يركز بشكل خاص على
تجنيد القاتلين الشباب وفق مراقبين فان
هذه الخطوه يمكن ان تزيد فجوه التوتر بين
الكريملين وقائد فاجنر الذي يوصل انتقاد
موسكو التي تسعى في كل مره لابطاء المكاسب
العسكريه خصوصا في بخموت التي باتت نقطه
محوريه في القتال حيث ان قوه فاجنر اسهمت
في السيطره على حوالي 50% من المدينه بعد
معارك قويه خاضها الجيش الروسي جنبا الى
جنب مع مجندي مجموعه فاجنر للسيطره على
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
قصص عيد الرئيس التونسي ينوي اعاده
العلاقات مع النظام السوري المنقطعه منذ
عام 2012 عده كتل برلمانيه تونسيه ادى
ايدت عوده العلاقات على امل ان يتعاود
نظام الاسد مع تحقيقات تجريها المحاكم
التونسيه في ملف تسفير تونسيين الى بؤر
التوتر في سوريا للقتاله في صفوف تنظيم
داعش علي العريض رئيس الوزراء التونسي
الاسبق التابع لحركه النهضه الاخوانيه كان
قد تم تحويله الى القضاء في ذات الملف
الرئيس التونسي قال ان مساله النظام في
سوريا تهم السوريين وحدهم وان تونس تتعامل
مع الدوله السوريه مؤكدا انه ليس هناك ما
يبرر ان يكون هنالك سفير لتونس في سوريا
وسفير لدمشق في تونس
ليس هناك ما يبرر ان لا يكون هناك سفير
لتونس في دمشق في الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه
وسفير للجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في تونس
مساله
النظام في سوريا مساله تهم السوريين وحدهم
نحن نتعامل مع الدوله السوريه اما
اختيارات الشعب السوري فهي اختياراته ولا
دخل لنا فيها اطلاقا
انضم الينا مشاهدينا من تونس خليل الرقيق
المحلل السياسي استاذ خليل يعني قبل ان
اخذ الشق الداخلي وهو موضوع النهضه وكل
الحسابات السياسيه بالشقه الخارجي عندما
قطعت تونس علاقاتها مع نظام السوري كان
السبب المعلن حينها هو قمع للتظاهرات
وللمعارضه وكل شيء اليوم ما الذي تغير
بهذا الملف هل تغير النظام السوري مع شعبه
وعندما يتحدث الرئيس عن ان الشعب السوري
هو من يقرر اي شعب ما هو معظم السوريين
اليوم يعني مهجرين
نعم اهلا وسهلا قبل كل شيء قلت وهذا واضح
ان السبب المعلن لقطع العلاقات مع سوريا
من طرف الرئيس الاسبق منصف المرزوقي في
خطوه انفراديه لم يستشير فيها احدا هو ما
سماه بالتظاهرات والحريات وغيره ولكن كلنا
نعرف بعد مسار كامل انا السبب العميق وراء
ذلك الاعلان هو انخراط تونس التي افتكها
الاخوان في محور تحالف اقليمي ودولي يهدف
الى اسقاط الانظمه واسقاط الدول الوطنيه
والتدخل فيها باراده خارجيه كانت معلومه
وبتدريبات وقعت في الخارج بمعنى نحن اليوم
نصحح وضعا قديما هذا الوضع هو اننا نعتبر
ان المجموعه العربيه بصفه عامه ليست فقط
دوائر شاركها وتعاون بل هي دوائر انتماء
عدنا الى انتمائنا الطبيعي للمجموعه
العربيه الى علاقاتنا الطبيعيه مع
المجموعه العربيه بقطع النظر عن الشان
الذكي لكل
اعلم اننا الان
فتاح العربي على سوريا
لا نستحق باي مسار كل الدول العربيه الان
في وارد اعاده تعريف علاقاتها وفق
المستجدات الجديده في الاقليم وفي المنطقه
ولكن نحن منذ البدايه كنا في علاقات
طبيعيه ثم انقطعت هذه العلاقات بفعل سياسي
هناك فرق بين العلاقه بين الشعوب والدول
المبنيه على الانتماء والتعاون والشراكه
وبين العلاقه بين الاجندات السياسيه
الاخوان المسلمون ارادوا ان ينخرطوا في
مسار داخل سوريا لا يهمنا في شيء هو مسار
داخلي يهم السوريين يهم الدوله السوريه
يهم اراده الشعب السوري الذي هو حر في
اختيار من يحكمه ومن لا يحكمه اذا هذا
العلاقات العرب
حتى وان كان الهدف هو اعاده تعريف يعني
العلاقه مع سوريا ولكن بهذا الملف ايضا
يعني لم يتم ذكر العمليه السياسيه الحل
السياسي في سوريا الذي يراعي ايضا حقوق
السوريين وهذا ما تنادي به الدول العربيه
وكل المجتمع الدولي لماذا تغاضى عن كل هذا
الموضوع وذهب الى علاقات كامله
لم نتغاضى عن كل المواضيع ونحن نتابع مثل
ما نتابع اي دوله باستقلاليه تامه
وباحترام لسياده السوريه كل الخطوات التي
ياخذها المجتمع الدولي كل المفاوضات
الموجوده في عدد من الدول الاوروبيه
والعربيه
يعني تسويه الوضع السوري لكن هذه تبقى
مساله ليس لنا ان نتدخل فيها مباشره مثل
الاخير لو سمحت العربيه في دوله اخرى
بموضوع التحقيقات بملف التسفير الى سوريا
طبعا هناك اليوم حسابات سياسيه داخليه
بتونس هل يعني يامل جانب التونسي ان يكون
هناك فعلا معطيات حقيقيه من قبل نظام
الاسد مع العلم ان هناك تشكيك بهذا
الموضوع
نعم لا بالتاكيد انا اقول لك بالتاكيد
لاني اعرف وتعرف عديد الوفود من المجتمع
المدني التونسي والبرلمان التونسي القديم
ل 2014 ان المعطيات متوفره لدى الجانب
السوري منذ 2016 وهي معطيات تخص تحركات
الارهابيين من تونس الى معبر انطقي في
تركيا وصولا الى سوريا وهذه التحقيقات
واكد لك انها ستفضح الحزب السياسي الذي
كان يحكم تونس وهو حركه النهضه وستحمله
المسؤوليه السياسيه والجنائيه في نقل عدد
مقاتلين الى سوريا الدوله السوريه عندها
انقطاع العلاقات كانت ترفض مد تونس بهذه
الوثائق لانها لا تعترف الا بالعلاقات بين
الدول يعني لا يمكن ان تسلم هذه الوثائق
الا دوله لدوله في اطار علاقات طبيعيه
استراتيجيه دبلوماسيه هذا الملف سيكون
معززا لملف انطلق بعده ملف التصفير وفيه
بطاقه ايداع في سجن في وزير الحكومه
الاسبق ووزير الداخليه الاسبق عليه
العريضه بعد التحقيقات امتدت لسنوات واشهر
اثبتت ضلوع حركه النهضه في تسفير
الارهابيين الى مواطن القتال شكرا لك
استاذ خليل الرقيقه المحلي السياسي حدثنا
من تونس
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
ما مصير مفقودي الزلزال العربيه تبحث في
الملف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لم ينالوا فرصه الانقاذ
من الزلزال لكنهم لم يحضروا ايضا بطقوس
الانتشار والدفن فبعد مرور خمسه اسابيع
على الكارثه عائله سوريه وتركيا لا تزال
تنتظر جثث اقاربها دون جدوى هؤلاء يحاولون
حل اللغز الاصعب في كوارث كهذه اين
المفقودين حيث اكدت محاميه سوريه عدم
قدرتها على ايجاد والدها في اي مكان
بالعالم لا تحت الانقاض ولا بالمستشفيات
السلطات بالبلدين قدمت معلومات شحيحه حول
عدد الاشخاص المفقودين لكن استاذا بالطب
الشرعي رجح فقدان نحو 1500 شخص في تركيا
وحدها طرق عده تقف وراء فقدان اشخاص اولها
حدوث فوضى اوليه حيث يرسل المصابون
لمستشفيات بعيده وربما ماتوا دون علم
اقاربهم ودفنوا كجثث مجهوله الهويه على
عجل وفي هذه الحاله قد تساعد البصمات
واختبارات الحمض النووي والصور
الفوتوغرافيه محاوله ربط الجثث المجهوله
الهويه طبعا باقاربها وبالفعل حصلت بعض
المطابقات اما اخرون فربما احترقوا بسبب
النيران او نقلوا كبقايا بعيدا عند ازاله
الانقاض عن طريق الخطا
[موسيقى]
الحرب على تيك توك الصيني تتواصل اجراءات
تقييد وحظر امتدت من الولايات المتحده الى
بلجيكا مرورا بالاتحاد الاوروبي ككتله
رئيس الوزراء البلجيكي اعلن حظر استخدام
التطبيق على موظفي الحكومه الاتحاديه
البلجيكيه على هواتفهم الخاصه وحذر من
المخاطر المرتبطه بالكميات الكبيره من
البيانات التي جمعها تيك توك المملوكه
لشركه صينيه ملزمه بالتعاون او ملزمه
بالتعاون مع اجهزه المخابرات الصينيه تيك
توك من جانبها اعربت عن خيبه امل من
القرار الذي قالت انه يستند الى معلومات
خاطئه اساسا
[موسيقى]
تطبيق تيك توك واحد من اشهر التطبيقات
الاجتماعيه المستخدمه في العالم حقق نجاحا
كبيرا خلال الفتره الاخيره خاصه بين
الشباب والاطفال ومع ذلك فان هذا التطبيق
يشكل مخاطر كثيره ولا ينبغي التعامل معه
بشكل طائش يقول خبراء يحتوي تيك توك
مشاهدينا على العديد من التحديات المختلفه
التي تشجع المستخدمين على القيامه بانشطه
خطره مثل القفز من الاماكن العاليه وهذا
يمكن ان يؤدي طبعا الى الاصابات الجسديه
وحتى الموت يمكن للمستخدمين ان ينشروا
معلومات خاصه عن انفسهم او عن اصدقائهم
دون ان يدركوا المخاطر التي يتعرضون لها
حيث يمكن استخدام هذه المعلومات بطرق غير
مشروعه كالسرقه والاحتيال والتزوير يمكن
ايضا ان يؤدي استخدام تيك توك لفترات
طويله الى الادمان والانعزال الاجتماعي
كما يحصل مع الاطفال ويمكن ان يؤثر ذلك
على الصحه النفسيه والعقليه للمستخدم لكن
مشاهدينا كل ما سبق من مخاطر لا ينطبق على
تيك توك فقط بل ايضا على كافه وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي اذا لم تستخدم بحكمه
وكل تلك المخاطر لم تكن السبب وراء حظر
التطبيق في كثير من الدول وانما السبب
الرئيسي يعود الى التحدي الامني واستخدام
المعلومات الشخصيه من قبل الحكومه الصينيه
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الموضوع معنا مشاهدينا
من جده عبر سكايب عادل الغامدي الباحث في
تقنيه وامن المعلومات استاذ عادل يعني
طبعا كل الاسباب التي يتم الحديث عنها هي
في يعني ميل والسبب الاساسي وهو موضوع
الامن القومي لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده هو طبعا في جانب وصوب
اخر هل يمكن حظر التطبيق بطريقه نهائيه
وكامله
اهلا وسهلا مساء الخير هو بالفعل الحرب قم
على تطبيق التيك توك الفتره الاخيره
بالنسبه للحظر التطبيق هو ممكن تقنيا
الدوله تقدر تحضر التطبيق زي ما دوله
الصين حاضره تطبيق الفيسبوك تقدر اي دوله
تبغى تحضر تطبيق معين حتقدر تستخدم برامج
الخوادم الخاصه فيها وتحضر تطبيق التيك
توك على المستخدمين يستخدمون البرامج اخرى
او برامج بديله لاستخدام تطبيق التيك توك
هذا باجابه مختصره على هل ممكن ان تحضر
نعم تقدر تحضر التيك توك وعلى المستخدم
يشوف طريقه اخرى اذا مصر انه يستخدم تطبيق
التيك توك
انتهاك الخصوصيه التي تتحدث عنها الدول
الاوروبيه والامريكيه مخاطر انتهاك
الخصوصيه هل يعني اليوم تنحصر فقط بتيك
توك او تنسحب على كل وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لان الناس يشاركون حياتهم
اليوميه معلومات شخصيه وكل ما الى هنالك
على هذه الوسائل
بصراحه جميع برامج تصنع اجتماعي تشارك
المعلومات هذه تشارك العنوان تشارك
البيانات شركه بالعكس يعني تجعل مواقع
ثانيه بتعطيك معلومات اكثر الفيسبوك
بيعطيك المدرسه بيعطيك الحي بيعطي زملائك
بيعطيك ابتدائي متوسط ثانوي جامعه بيعطيك
سنه تخرج بيعطيك حفله عيد ميلاد
بتقدر ترجع المعلومات اكثر لكن هو التوجه
التيك توك انه هم ماخذين نقطه معينه
التيك توك وبالتالي هي ليست هو ليس موضوع
جمع بيانات فقط يعني حتى الجهات الامريكيه
تجمع بيانات وانها هي يعني الحرب
الامريكيه الصينيه بموضوع
نعم هي حرب امريكيه صينيه بحته ما فيها اي
شيء اما كل البرامج بتقوم بنفس العمل
بتقوم بنفس جمع المعلومات يعني حتى شركه
تيك توك قالت انه السيرفرات الخاصه
بالمستخدمين الامريكيين موجوده داخل
امريكا والباك اب حقها موجود في دوله
ماليزيا ما في اي شيء عندنا في الصين فهم
يقولوا لا في كل واحد قاعد يكذب الثاني
بينما جميع برامج او اجتماعي يعني
الفيسبوك في كوارث من المعلومات للشخص
تشاركها بيشاركها معلومات وبشارك صوره
وبشارك اصدقائه وبشارك اصدقائه اصدقائه
انتهاك الخصوصيه وجمع المعلومات تنسحب على
كل وسائل التواصل والباقي سياسه بحث شكرا
لك استاذ عادل الغامدي الباحث في تقنيه
وامن المعلومات على وجودك معنا
في ذات الملف تيك توك يرد على اتهامه
بالتجسس عبر اطلاق خدمات جديده منها فلتر
بولد الذي اثار جدلا وصفه خبراء التجميل
بهجمه لاسطوره الجمال المثالي
بينما تلاحقه اتهامات بالتجسس من دول
غربيه يواجه التطبيق الصيني تيك توك هذه
الاتهامات باطلاق خدمات جديده تحمل مزايا
مختلفه مثل فلتر بولد جلامور وخدمه سيريز
التي اتاحت لصناع المحتوى نشر مقاطع مصوره
تصل مده كل منها الى 20 دقيقه ليفتح
التطبيق الصيني ملامح منافسه شرسه امام
تطبيقات مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى
كفايسبوك وانستجرام وحتى يوتيوب الخدمات
الجديده المعلنه لتيك توك اثارت نوعا من
التساؤلات لدى المستخدمين ازاء قدره هذه
المؤثرات الخاصه المطوره عبر الذكاء
الاصطناعي على تجميل وجوههم
لتعاود الجدل بعيدا عن تهم التجسس والحديث
عن معايير الجمال التي تسوق لها شبكات
الاجتماعي خبراء التجميل يقولون ان هذا
النوع من الفلاتر يعد احدث هجمه لاسطوره
الجمال المثالي مما يجعل مستخدمي هذا
النوع من الفلاتر ينشطون الى استخدام
الحميات المفرطه وينقص الثقه بالنفس لديهم
تطبيق تيك توك الذي بلغ عدد مستخدميه
مليار مستخدم نشط شهريا خلال شهر سبتمبر
يعتبر في الولايات المتحده تهديدا للامن
القومي من جانب مسؤولين ومحليين كثيرين
يتهمون التطبيق بنقل معلومات عن
المستخدمين لبكين وهو ما تنفيه الشركه
[موسيقى]
غواصات نوويه ستجوب المحيط الهادئ قريبا
اثر صفقه ثلاثيه بين كل من استراليا من
طرف وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده من طرف
اخر لتثير حفيظه الصين التي تعتبر المشروع
خطيرا عليها
صفقه ثلاثيه ستغير الوجود العسكريه في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ وتجلب اليها غواصات
بالدفع النووي
الاتفاق الثلاثي بين كل من استراليا
والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
5 غواصات نوويه خلال العقد القادم من طراز
يو اس اس فرجينيا والغواصات البريطانيه
الهجوميه وما يميزها هو صعوبه الرصدها
وامكانيه السفر لمسافات طويله بالاضافه
لقدرتها على حمل الصواريخ عابره للقارات
الصفقه جزء من تحالف اوكوس الثلاثي
الهاتفي الى تشارك التكنولوجيا العسكريه
والذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يضم الدول السابقه
تحالف جاء عام 2021 كانت فعلا على نشاط
الصين المتنامي في المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ
اتفاقيه اوكوس تدور حول المستقبل كما انها
تطفي طابعا رسميا للقيم والمصالح المشتركه
لدولنا الثلاث
اعتبرت المشروع الجديد خطيرا هادفا الى
حصارها رد فعل مشابه لاعلان تحالف اوكوس
عندما ادانت الخارجيه الصينيه التصدير
التكنولوجيا النوويه الامريكيه الا ان
كبرى دول اسيا كانت قد اعلنت عن زياده
بنسبه
7.2% من ميزانيتها الدفاعيه لعام 2023
لتكون اكبر زياده منذ العام 2019
اذا عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
في وقت تتجهدو العالم لزياده ايام العطل
الاسبوعيه الى ثلاثه تاخذ كوريا الجنوبيه
الاتجاه المعاكس وتمدد ساعات العمل حكومه
اقترحت زياده ساعات العمل الاسبوعيه الى
69 ساعه بدلا من 52 ساعه طويله اصلا
الاقتراح اثار غضب المعارضه التي تخشى من
اخلال التوازن بين العمل والحياه في بلد
معروف بادمان العمل كما رجحت المعارضه ان
تخاطر الخطه الجديده لزياده البطاله لانها
تتيح لاصحاب العمل تسريح العمال ومطالبه
الباقين بالعمل لساعات اطول وفي مقارنه
بسيطه مع شعوب اخرى يعمل الكوريون
الجنوبيون بمعدل
1915 ساعه سنويا مقابل
1490 للفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا
سعر
دونيون موجود بين ايران تكذب
طهره 10 مليارات دولار مقابل رهان
امريكيين
متهور سيحاسبه تاريخ ولن ادعمه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
ويثير ذعر الاسواق الامريكيه والبريطانيه
[موسيقى]
بلجيكا تنضم لقائمه مقاطعي تيك توك
والعربيه تفتح ملف امن المعلومات على
منصات التواصل
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
شكرا لحسن المتابعه والى اللقاء والان الى
360 مع زميله ميسون نويد ميسون مساء الخير
وماذا لديك الليله مساء الخير ليان طبعا
سنتحدث عن الانباء التي تتحدث عن خلاف
وتوتر بين اداره بايدن واوكرانيا ايضا
لدينا موضوعنا في واشنطن لتحريرها اموال
لايران مقررها موضوع الثالث التحركات طبعا
لضمان ودائع بنك سيليكون غالي وسنترقب
طبعا الاوسكار المترقب هذه بعد ساعات
قليله تفضلي ميسون الهواء لك